avec william julier avocat spécialiste
des droits de l'homme bonsoir willem
julien merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france vous voyez âprement
réagir aux propos de notre confrère ça
vous choque ce qui s'est passé sur le
terrain c'est extraordinaire j'ai écouté
avec beaucoup d'attention le témoignage
qui vient de nous être livrés par par
votre confrère
témoignages qui a apporté des
informations nous n'avions pas encore
entendu et notamment étant avocat
évidemment j'y suis particulièrement
sensible le fait qu'ils avaient été dans
l'impossibilité de voir un avocat d'être
assisté par un avocat et d'être assisté
par lui pendant la garde à vue mais
aussi pendant le procès parce qu'on
comprend qu'un procès a eu lieu de façon
expéditive et en violation des règles
élémentaires
qui sont garanties mais on en parlera
sans doute dans une minute par le droit
européen et il ya une directive
européenne sur l'accès à l'avocat la
pologne ne peut priver quelqu un de ces
d'un avocat lors qu'il a été interpellé
évidemment ça allait être ma prochaine
question quel est le droit qui prévaut
dans ce cas là s de droit français on a
effectivement le droit à l'assistance
d'un avocat ou le drapeau n'est ni le
droit européen 1 vous dites alors ce
sera pas le droit français parce que le
fait que cette interpellation est
concerné des ressortissants français
n'en portent pas la compétence du droit
français par contre la question en effet
savoir si cette droit polonais ou le
droit européen
la réponse c'est les deux le principe
étant que le droit polonais doit être
conforme au droit européen le droit
européen en tout cas et on parlera aussi
sans doute dans une seconde
jusqu'à une décision récente
de droit polonais doit être conforme au
droit européen qui lui est supérieur
c'est la primauté du droit européen sur
le droit national et
sauf si la pologne décide de sortir des
règles de l'union européenne auxquels
elle a décidé d'adhérer il y a quand
même maintenant un certain temps eh bien
elle doit respecter le droit européen et
notamment cette directive européenne
donc ce qui s'est passé là est une
violation flagrante de la norme
européenne qui devra emporter sans doute
des sanctions supplémentaires on verra
ça dans les jours et les semaines à
venir au delà de nos confrères à ce que
justement c'est une affaire qui peut
aller plus loin puisque comme vous dites
il ya un droit européen jusqu'à preuve
du contraire et jusqu'à présent la
pologne fait partie de l'union
européenne ça veut dire la pologne on va
pas faire évidemment un procès à
l'emporte-pièce en cinq minutes sur ce
gâteau mais tout de même ça voudra dire
que la pologne a appliqué son propre
droit ou détriment du droit européen
vous l'avait dit et ça pourrait être
l'objet peut-être d'un harpon légitime
oui je pense que seul sera je pense
qu'il y aura moyen pour vos confrères
d'engager une action et éventuellement
devant la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme mais au-delà de ça je pense que
ce qui doit être rappelé aujourd'hui
c'est que la pologne commet des
violations des droits fondamentaux des
droits de l'homme en matière de presse
en matière de liberté de la presse mais
aussi en matière d'indépendance de la
justice qui ont amené les autorités
européennes
on en a parlé beaucoup ces derniers
jours à sanctionner de façon extrêmement
lourde la pologne si elle continue dans
la voie qu'elle a choisi d'emprunter il
ya maintenant plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années qui est une voie de
destruction des fondements de l'état de
droit et parmi les fondements de l'état
de droit il y à l'indépendance du
troisième pouvoir le pouvoir judiciaire
et il y a aussi peut-être le respect de
ce quatrième pouvoir qui est celui de la
presse donc c'est un phénomène qui n'est
pas nouveau il y a là une nouvelle
manifestation est bien de cette machine
de destruction de la règle de droit et
de l'état de droit en pologne et je
pense en effet que ce cet épisode
malheureux pour pour vos confrères est
une illustration supplémentaire de la
très mauvaise voie dans laquelle la
pologne est engagée précise que nos
collègues ont été arrêtés dans une zone
interdite un selon les autorités
polonaises
pourquoi cette zone est elle interdite
aux journalistes pourquoi cette opacité
qui peut surprendre quand on est
journaliste a priori c'est vrai qu'on on
doit rendre compte on peut rendre compte
sur plusieurs terrains là c'est un petit
peu étonnant si vous permettez une
réponse directe c'est ce que j'ai
commencé à dire sauf que là on est dans
la démonstration avec un cran de
violence encore supplémentaires j'ai lu
que cette interdiction
de pénétrer dans cette zone là ne datent
pas de quelques jours donc elle ne date
pas de la crise la plus récente fracture
d'interdiction qui a été promulguée par
le président le 2 septembre donc ça fait
un moment que ça dure et je crois que
cette interdiction entre dans cette
machine de destruction de la presse
indépendante
c'est un abus de droit cela en vaut à
ses pires que ça je crois que c'est la
destruction de l'état démocratique
polonais je crois que il y à
une réflexion et la mise en place d'un
système de destruction des médias
indépendants dans ce pays ont pas le
temps d'en parler maintenant mais il ya
eu des des lois qui ont été votées pour
empêcher les médias étrangers
il y avait des participations dans une
chaîne en l'occurrence cette
participation américaine il ya une loi
votée sur mesure pour empêcher ce média
de continuer à exercer il y a eu des
attaques contre les médias indépendants
très nombreuses par levier économique
pour les priver de leurs moyens de
subsistance
il y à des mesures de rétorsion des
poursuites en diffamation systématiques
contre les médias indépendants il y à
une opération de destruction de toute
voix qui permet d'éclairer non seulement
le peuple polonais mais aussi le monde
extérieur sur un certain nombre de
choses qui se déroulent et sans doute
avec un objectif qui est d'obtenir une
réélection qui sans museler la presse
indépendante semble compromise on l'a vu
en hongrie et je crois que ce qui est en
train de se passer en pologne est est
une opération similaire ma dernière
question justement dans le prolongement
le fait que ça soit erté france
donc lié à la russie mais d'allier la
russie est ce que ça a plus changé
quelque chose apparemment il ya aussi
les jours nice d'arte et peut-être
qu'ils ont confondu au niveau de la
sémantique mais enfin est ce que ça
change quelque chose dans ce cas de
figure selon vous écoutez je ne sais pas
si vos confrères ont été ciblés en
particulier parce qu'ils étaient rt j'ai
plutôt l'impression
et je ne sais pas exactement quelle a
été la ligne éditoriale de rt sur la
question si elle a été peut-être un peu
plus tranché que les autres peut-être la
réponse à votre question est oui je
pense que la pologne aujourd'hui s'en
prend à tout voie de presse indépendante
rt sans doute été considérées comme
parmi celles merci en tout cas william
juliet d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france ce soir je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat spécialiste des droits
de l'homme merci à vous